receive a presentation from nevada
department of
transportation interstate 15 tropicana
avenue design
build project and direct staff
accordingly
madam chair we do have a miss lynette
russell who is online to provide the
presentation for us today okay
thank you good morning as stated i am
lynette russell
assistant chief of the project
management division at nvon
and i'd like to thank you for the
opportunity to meet with you this
morning and provide you with an
update on the i-15 traffic canada
interchange design level project
we last heard from the department late
last summer when jeff larue
provided you with an update jeff has
since been promoted
and i've taken on the role of project
manager on this important and exciting
project
as awkward as it is to do this virtually
i very much appreciate the option
i returned from south africa on sunday
and although i had the requisite
negative coveted test for the return
flight
i'm self quarantining for a week to make
sure i didn't bring any special bugs
back with me
having said all that i'd like to confirm
that you can hear me okay
if that's the case then i'd like to go
ahead and get started so
uh next slide please
great so as previously stated my name is
lynette russell
i'm the assistant chief of the project
management division as well
as the project manager on this i-15
tropicana interchange design
build project i have jack showstrom with
me here today also from the ca group
to help answer any questions that may
come up it's been several months since
you last heard from us so i'd like to
start this morning
yep still this morning by reminding you
of the project
what it entails and why we're doing it
i'd also like to inform you about some
additional scope that's been added since
we last
let you know where we are in the process
and when you might start seeing
something
actually happening out there if possible
i'd like to hold any questions until the
end but if there's something really
pressing
please just feel free to jump in anytime
so
next slide please
okay let's kick this off with a brief
reminder about this exciting project
what are we doing and why next slide
please
so as you know the tropicana interchange
is one of the busiest
if not the busiest interchange in the
state
i think of it as the gateway to the
south end of the iconic las vegas strip
but it's also a critical point of
connection for accessing
the t-mobile arena mccarran
international airport
unlv and of course the recently
completed allegiant stadium
originally constructed in the 60s the
interchange has several deficiencies
that this project will address
if you've driven along i-15 headed to
the north i'm sure you've noticed that
this is a location where traffic really
starts to back up
the reason for that is that this is
we've widened i-15 from the south
up to this point of the tropicana bridge
is too short to allow any future
widening
so we need to make the bridge longer in
order to continue widening to the north
you may have also noticed in particular
on the south side of the structure
that the bridge has been hit several
times
for that reason we need to make the
bridge taller
on the tropicana roadway the operations
where the ramps meet the roadway are
starting to break down with
unanticipated volumes of traffic
so we need to increase the capacity of
the roadway and turn movements by adding
more lanes to the ramps and the bridge
next slide please
with all of the incredible improvements
in the vicinity this has become a more
pedestrian focused area than anyone
could have ever anticipated
well there are pedestrian field
facilities in place we want to increase
the capacity and connectivity of those
facilities
and make it easier for pedestrians to
get where they want to go
so next slide please
you don't need a traffic model to
recognize that one of the things that
contributes to the operational breakdown
of the interchange
is the current density of signals along
tropicana
in particular the signal at dean martin
is very close to the signal for the
southbound ramps
excuse me to remedy this issue this
project will eliminate the signal at
dean martin
next slide please
the signal will lead to a right in right
out configuration
that will improve traffic flow through
the area and reduce conflicts
access to all business area will be
maintained with circular frontage roads
in keeping with our goal to improve
pedestrian capacity and connectivity
10-foot sidewalks will be added to both
sides of the roadway with paths and
stairs connecting tropicana to both
d martin on the west side and frank
sinatra on the east side of i-15
next slide please
with the previously mentioned increased
clearance of tropicana bridge over i-15
the clearance between the tropicana
roadway and the flyover
structure becomes an issue for taller
loads in order to remedy this
conflict excuse me and also to
accommodate the numerous other project
improvements to the area
the department will need to replace the
existing flyover
next slide
you can see here the flyover is in a
slightly different location
the pillars that support the bridge are
also in slightly different locations
and you'll have to take my word that the
clearance of the new structure is more
than adequate for safe passage along the
tropicana roadway
next slide please
in addition to improvements at tropicana
avenue we're going to be constructing an
hov ramp
at the harman overpass next slide
this will give additional access
to the resort corridor and provide some
relief to the adjacent interchanges
next slide please the department is also
looking to expand its active
traffic management sites or atms similar
to what was installed as part of project
neon
the atm infrastructure will enhance
safety provide
real-time information to drivers and
provide an opportunity to actively
manage the freeway corridor
next slide please
okay since our last update we have
expanded the scope to include two
additional major items of work
first as shown on the right the
department has been working on the
design of a pavement preservation
project between hacienda and warm
springs
with the work we'll be doing for the new
atm infrastructure
the footprint of this tropicana project
goes right through that pavement
preservation
area in the interest of saving time
cost and the inconvenience to the
traveling public associated with putting
out
a separate project tidbit and
construction the department has decided
to include the pavement preservation
work in this project
this effort will include mill and
overlay of i-15 down to warm springs
full depth pavement repair where
required
rich deck rehabilitation and other
miscellaneous improvements and
maintenance items
second as shown on the left side of the
screen the clark county water
reclamation district has requested that
not include a replacement of its older
less efficient systems near the
intersection of dean martin and
tropicana
as part of this work two existing
crossings of i-15
are proposed to be replaced by a single
larger pipe
connecting sewer van holes near the
excalibur new york new york
intersections
although this work will be done for the
water reclamation district it will be
constructed as part of the tropicana
design build project
increasing possible impacts to the
traveling public in regards to lane
closures and disruptions on dean martin
and tropicana
but sewer service will not be
interrupted again
doing this work as part of this design
build project will ultimately
save the time cost and inconvenience of
setting out another project on the heels
of the completion of this project next
slide please
so our project goals have not changed
since our original presentation
but i wanted to restate them here
because i think they're really important
uh the department has evaluated the
critical elements to make this project a
success
all the while balancing speed and
construction efficiency
with reducing impacts to the traveling
public and local businesses as much as
possible
we know there will be many impacts to
the tropicana interchange and its
adjacent connected roadways
through it all the department has
focused on maintaining i-15
as a critical economic and
transportation link
even so closures and lane reductions
will be required
similarly closures on adjacent roadways
are inevitable
however trafficking will require to have
through traffic maintained at all times
and full closures of any streets will be
limited to those times when there are
absolutely no other options
to completing major construction
activities
all lane reductions and full closures on
both i-15
and the local roadways will be minimized
and balanced with accommodating area
special events
business access and pedestrian
connectivity over the duration of the
construction phase
next slide please
so businesses and their viability are
very important to the department
and to the community and we've made
maintaining access and coordinating with
businesses
one of the major goals for this project
at no time
will a business access be completely
closed off
the department has been proactive in
meeting with and working with
stakeholders throughout the design
development process we will continue to
work closely with stakeholders
immediately adjacent to the project
as well as businesses in the surrounding
areas
once we selected our design build team
we'll establish regular meetings with
all stakeholders to provide an
opportunity for open discussion
while in advance of any of the
inevitable disruptions and detours
next slide please this corridor is full
of critical
utility infrastructure that will require
protection in most cases
and relocations and limited scenarios
similar to the department approach to
vehicle and pedestrian movement through
the project during the course of
construction
we're committed to ensuring all
utilities remain functional and
in service throughout the project
allowing utilities
uninterrupted service to their customers
next slide please
as part of our goal to limit impacts to
local businesses
we're focused on driving solutions that
minimize or mitigate
impacts to visibility of businesses and
their advertising
next slide three-dimensional models will
be created of the final design to
among other things ensure that this goal
is accomplished next slide please
additionally the department has already
begun critical coordination
with the army corps of engineers to
advance the project's 408 permit
we're currently in the process of
responding to comments from the course
recent review
and anticipate having that permit in
place by summer
we're also coordinating with utility
owners throughout the corridor to help
them understand the improvements and how
we will work together to mitigate
impacts
we are proactively working with various
stakeholders like yourselves
to discuss the project listen to
concerns and adjust our technical
requirements accordingly
some of the stakeholders we've been in
discussion with include clark county
public works
clark county regional flood control
district clark county water reclamation
district
the resort corridor mobility association
mgm ri and stations casinos
this is by no means an all-inclusive
list of the stakeholders with whom we've
been working
lastly we've met with various property
owners throughout the project
limits where right-of-way may be needed
we're starting the appraisal process and
reaching out once again
to impacted property owners next slide
please
so where do we go from here what happens
next and what can you expect to see in
the coming months
next slide so we completed the
environmental phase about a year
ago and we are now in the middle of the
process that will allow us to bring on
our design build team
the draft rfp was issued in november and
final rfp
was just issued last week following
assorted one-on-one meetings and
critical
alternative concept discussions
proposals are due back to the department
in june the proposals will then be
evaluated
and we will anticipate so we currently
anticipate selecting our design build
team
like this summer design and construction
phases will begin once the
transportation board approves of the
design build team selection
and contract this is expected to take
place at their regular meeting in
september
design activities will begin immediately
upon selection of the team and
typically we can expect to see
construction activities begin
as soon as three months later design and
then construction
will run continuously until project
closeout which is
anticipated to be about three years next
slide please
okay what are our next steps and what
can you expect as we move forward
uh next slide as we're now
entering the proposal solicitation and
evaluation phase we do not really
anticipate much if any additional
information or significant change
prior to the award of the design bill
contract in september
on the off chance this should change you
will be hearing from me again
with an update regarding those changes
as it stands now i anticipate returning
to this board of county commissioners
with our next project update
at the end of september once the state
transportation board has approved our
design
and build team selection and contract
between now and then
i and my team are available to answer
any questions that may arise
uh next slide please
okay wow can't really see that extension
on there too well
but this is my contact information for
your use
um at this time i'd like to thank you
for your
interest in the project for letting me
give you this little debrief
and jack and i are available to answer
any questions
that you may have at this point well
thank you very much ms russell
we it has been something on all of our
minds because we've
since it was the notion was introduced
we've been waiting anxiously and we
hear from a number of groups that intend
to compete
vigorously to secure this work are there
questions that
any of you have commissioner jones
sure and thank you miss russell for your
presentation i did have a question for
you
on several slides there's a there's a
bicyclist on there does that
imply that bicycles are actually going
to be accommodated on this intersection
or it was just kind of thrown on there
uh yeah jack you want to go ahead and
step in
yeah so um that's typically n dot
standard slide has that on it
um i apologize if there is any confusion
in that
um what we are um doing though is we
have worked with the rtc
to look at what may be planned for
bicycles in the future
um currently tropicana is not
a bicycle route and it is not planned to
be a bicycle route
however you know we are proposing ten
foot wide sidewalks
on both the north and south side that
would allow
uh cyclists if they do end up on
tropicana and need to use
the tropicana facility to walk their
bikes on a wider sidewalk
providing both ada compliance and a
safer area
in general for all pedestrians so i hope
that answers your question and
i'm sorry for any confusion commissioner
naft
uh thank you vice chairman um uh could
you speak a little bit too
i noticed that that timeline uh as an
example bleeds right into uh the
potential for
a super bowl right here um in clark
county could you speak a little bit to
special events more broadly and how the
construction
schedule will consider those major
events knowing that uh
hopefully at the by the time you're in
construction phase we'll be ready
to welcome people back
a minute did you want me to take this
one uh sure
okay um so um we are
accommodating um right now special
events
and what what we're planning to do with
those special events
is the design builder that we select
will be required to
have i-15 and a certain number of lanes
on tropicana and adjacent roadways open
um during all the special events that
we've identified
and the super bowl ops you know
obviously would be one of those events
that would be
large enough that it's going to make
that list in the future
but we will be working with the design
builder to identify
any uh future special events that are
significant both
locally in the interchange vicinity as
well as regionally
to make sure that there's a adequate
capacity on i-15 to move travelers
from california back and forth from home
to to the events
as well as locals those events
and special events are going to be set
up so that no
i-15 closures or significant reductions
in lanes will be occurring during
special events that we've identified
thank you very much do you know i don't
know if at this point you can specify
what the
threshold would be for a special event
or do you intend on working with the
lvcva
um to identify those
uh so right now the department has not
established a
threshold what we have done is we've
looked at
previous projects that have accommodated
special events
those special events lists we've also
coordinated with clark county department
of public works
on the development of our contract
documents
um and they uh dennis and his group have
had an opportunity to review the list of
events that we have currently
and then again we will be evaluating
that list as the project continues
to make sure that we accommodate events
that would be impacted if we were to
say close the interchange for a weekend
we really don't want to do that
when there's an event weekend in town
thank you and and i might just add it
would be really
helpful it will continue to be really
helpful that you
are in constant communication with our
public works office
and they with the members of this
commission so that we can
help get the word out it's sometimes
it's uh
really all about communication and right
now this is
looks awfully daunting given the
prospects of
conflict uh with the events that
have been mentioned by uh commissioner
naf so
that's really important to us are there
other commissioners that have questions
or comments
mr segerbloom i just want to ask a
question um
hypothetically if as infrastructure
money came from washington d.c and we
had a ton of money come out
could you speed the process up um
work 24 hours a day seven days a week
kind of thing
it's uh it's a delicate balance out
there to be honest with you
we are intending to go as quickly as we
can possibly go
but we need to balance our speed of
construction
with the needs for our stakeholders and
businesses in the area
um
so yeah i'm not sure if there's enough
money at some point to
make it go like in a week or two that
would be fantastic
at some point you run up against the
ability to get things done quickly
and with maintaining accesses and
movement of vehicles and pedestrians
through the area
jack do you have anything to add to that
i do
we definitely understand the the
potential for impacts of this project as
well as
um fully understand that you cannot
build something on top of itself without
having some adverse impact
when we set up the initial project
schedule um
we developed a schedule that assumed a
two-shift day
um and we still ended up with about a
three-year construction duration that
you see in the now that lynette
presented in her schedule
um we did look at a three shift day
um but i believe um we backed off of
requiring a three shift day of our
contractor but that's not to preclude
the
design build proposer teams from
proposing to have a three shift day
in order to you know advance the work
quickly
anything more from members of the board
we thank you very much for the
presentation the
information and we look forward to
hearing a whole lot more from you
over time so uh vice commissioner
vice chairman gibson before we uh step
off i just wanted to
follow up and let you know that we have
been and will continue to be in very
close communication with the county on
this project
uh public works has been really
instrumental in helping us develop our
technical provisions
and uh they're gonna be taking ownership
of some parts of this project
as well and it is it is a daunting
project
it is a little bit intimidating just the
uh heavy traffic volumes for this area
um and coordinating all of the
maintenance of traffic
and movement of traffic but i would say
it's daunting but not insurmountable
we will get through this we got through
some pretty difficult construction in
the past
and it needs to happen
unfortunately so this is the time
we'll work on this together and get
through it so thank you again for your
time today